♪ ♪ ♪
JEAN-FRANÇOIS BÉLANGER
- C'esececececret bien gardé,
un coin de campagne sur la rive
sud du Saint-Laurent, tout près
de la mettre. Trait d'union
entre Beauharnois
et Châteauguay. Sept kilomètres
de côtes, jalonnés de résidences
de luxe, de quais privés sur
un vaste plan d'eau, terrainde s
de sports nautiques.
Mais la ville de Léry est
surtout connue pour son golf
qui attire les adeptes
de toute la région.
Et alors que la campagne
électorale amorce son dernier
droit, elle s'immisce aussi
sur le vert.
(cris d'exclamation)
- Ça c'est drôle, on a l'air
tous les quatrarararartis
différents.
- C'est propice à se taquiner
entre nous autres.
- Moi,oioioiois que les jeunes
partis ont de très bonnes idées,
mais moi, je crois bien que
la CAQ mérite un autre mandat.
- Avec Legault, qu'irqrqrqrque,
qu'il arrête de faire sa loi.
- Je reviens à mes vieilles
habitudes si on veut puis
je vais voter Parti québécois.
- J'ai jasé parti politiques
avec mes amis, mais euh....
j'ai de la misère encore à faire
mon choix. C'est dur.
- Citoyens d'une ville
baromètre, les électeurs
de Léry sont le reflet des
intentions de vote ailleurs
au Québec. La ville est
d'ailleurs représentative
à plus ititititre, car les
défis, les problèmes vécus ici
sont loin d'être uniques.
- Ici, ça va être la rue Alain,
qui est un ancien professeur
d'école.
- Léry est en pleine
transformation. Une nouvelle
école, un nouveau quar
résidentiel.
- Donc, c'est ça, ce quartier
comme vous le voyez,
c'est 200 leleleles maisons,
et éventuellement 200 autres
maisons derrière, là-bas.
- Une fierté, mais en même temps
un casse-tête pour le maire
de la petite ville confrontée
simultanément aux problèmes
de pénurie de logements
d'étalement urbain.
Des enjeux selon lui absents
dempmpmpmpagne.
KEVIN BOYLE, maire de Léry
- Je reste sur ma faim un peu.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai besoin pourms
ne semblent pas l'offrir.
- Kevin Boyle se désole surtout
du fait que le sentiment
d'urgence qui l'anime
ne semble pas partagé par tous.
- L'environnement, il faut
s'en occuper tout de suite et
maintenant. C'est aujourd'hui,
ce n'est pas demain.
- Une question au coeur
des préoccupations ici alors
que la moitié de la ville est
privée d'égouts et d'aqueduc.
- Bonjour Madame Audet.
Kevin Boyle, le maire de Léry.
- Oui, ça va bien?
- Ça va très bien, vous-même?
- Oui, merci.
- C'est le cas d'Eve-Marie
Audette, forcée de boire
de l'eau en bouteille,
car celle de son puit est
impropre à la consommation.
- S'il y avait quoi que ce soit
quand pouvait faire de plus,
qu'est-ce que vous demanderiez?
EVE-MARIE AUDET,
résidente de Léry
- Je le conçois pas encore qu'en
2022, à 20 quelques kilomètres
de la ville de Montr
ce serait juste normal
d'avoir de l'eau.
On est en 2022.
- De l'eau propre dans son
robinet, mssssssssi dans
son environnement. Un besoin
essentiel qui guidera le vote de
cette jeune mère de famille.
- Pour moi, c'est primordial que
çasssssssse. Ce n'est pas normal
que des gens rejettent leurs
égouts dans le lac en 2022.
- La ville vient d'agrandir
son installation de traitementdi
pour projet d'offrir égouts
et aqueducs à tous les citoyens.
Des infrastructures essentielles
et pourtant impossibles à
réaliser sans l'aide de Québec.
- Les coûts sont exorbitants.
Ils sont aux alentours
de 65 millions minimums.
Notre budget annuel est
de 4,9 millions.
Donc c'est ridicule. Donc, si le
gouvernement ne nous appuie pas,
ne nous aide pas, on ne peut pas
fa p p p projet seul.
- Et les conséquences
du statu quo dépassent largement
les limites de la municipalité.t
désuètes, maintenant souvent,
elles polluent non seulement
la nappe phréatique, les puits,.
- Un discours qui rejoint bien
des citoyens à Léry. Car comme
Eve-Marie, c'est l'environnement
qui a poussé beaucoup de gens
à s'installer ici.
- On a la chance d'habiter sur
le bord du fleuve, qui est,
à mon avis un des joyaux
du Québec. On doit le préserver.
ANDRÉ CARON, résident de Léry
- Moi, j'aimerais ça qu'on parle
davantage des changements
climatiques. Parce que d'une
part, c'est effectivement ce...
il va avoir un impact su,,,,
sur les générations futures.
C'est quoi la priorité, ça ce
devrait être ça selon
- Alors que les électeurs ici
se sentent courtisés par tous
les partis, le maire croit
que Léry va conserver son statut
de ville baromètre, mais il
n'exclut pas les surprises.
- Le gouvernement de Monsieur
Legault a probablement
a un support ici à ville de
Léry. Mais encore une fois,
est-ce que c'est tous les
citoyens? C'est difficile
àdire à Léry, parce que
Québec solidaire est là.
Et les jeunes sont là et
l'environnement est important
énormément à Léry.
- Le 3 octobre, si les électeurs
de Léry risquent de suivre
encore une fois les vents
dominants, leur vote pourrait
aussi révéler les prémices
d'un vent de changement
qui place l'environnemen